how much time did you have with Joaquin
Phoenix before principal photography
yeah it's a cameraman you know a
cinematographer you you don't
necessarily spend that much time it
depends on the movie of course but it
depends also on the director and how
much rehearsing they do and you may have
if you have a director that does a ton
of rehearsing you may spend more time
prior to the movie starting working with
those actors and understanding a little
bit of them and they're certainly
filmmakers like Sydney the Med and other
guys that like hurts the whole movie
with all the actors and Todd's not one
of those guys Joaquin I think is also
not necessarily one of those big
rehearsal guys I think he's a classic
gamer in sports metaphors
he just wants when it happens he wants
to be captured and he sort of wants it
to be when the movies happening for real
so my interactions with Joaquin were
very very small and nominal leading up
to the first day of shooting I'd see him
for makeup hair tests and certainly when
he was like in the office trying the
makeup on for a couple times we would
I'd come in I'd take some still pictures
of him I'm gonna have conversations of
Todd about but it wasn't like we spent
much time together at all my first real
interactions with Akeem in a real sense
was basically day one of shooting
watching him perform like for the first
time first shot you know and and then
over the course of making the movie we
shot the movie in 58 days I then the
relationship really formed and you know
became a relationship by the end where
there was a lot more interaction
conversations and certainly I think we
both understand hood each other a little
bit more he understood what I was trying
to do with the movie I certainly of
course had seen what he was doing with
the movie and so there was a lot more
interaction by the end and his ability
to make this character who in the end is
is powerful in a destructive way but
seems so fragile so I mean there's so my
arms around well Arthur I felt so like
he just very well that's the whole
beauty of the way he sort of built the
arc of the character with him and Todd
is its it is
like it's me meek is one word but it's
not really that he's just a he's just a
gentle person like his place in the
movie in the in the early stages is one
of you know accommodating to some extent
right you know this there's this just
like a there's a there's a sense of each
sense real human sense to him I mean he
just really created a very human
character that has all the frailties and
and all the things and and that makes it
even the power of him wanting to be a
comedian which is such a high-profile I
I mean to me comedians and obviously
with Todd having done so many comedies
and I've certainly shot a lot of
comedies comedians are the most
fascinating people and I feel like to
stand up and do comedy is the hardest
thing in all of the creative arts I
really believe that I think you are the
most vulnerable and naked because jokes
are jokes right like you go out to set
out to do comedy it's like what his mom
says is don't you have to be funny to be
a comedian it's like it's cut and dry
it's black and white like you stand out
in front in a spotlight and you try to
tell jokes if people aren't laughing
essentially you're not a comedian and
it's pretty straightforward and there's
not a lot of argument and you go out and
make something that's supposed to move
people generally speaking you don't know
that and you're not knowing it instantly
you don't sense it from the audience
there it's a lot of internal stuff and I
respect so much anybody who tries
stand-up comedian stand-up comedy said
to me what a cool device to take this
person that's so small and like you say
you want to hug him because he's he's
obviously dresses up like a clown and he
has to perform so he has that part of
him but that dichotomy of character the
fact that he is this person that like
even when he's stretching his shoes and
you see the frailty of his body and how
skinny is and when even when when he
gets the gun from Randall he's even in
that moment he's just like I'm not
supposed to have a gun like it's all
very small and all
very and I think those elements of
Arthur's character and what what Keane
did with them and Todd of course is to
me is such a beautiful thing because you
see this massive Toccata me even within
the same human being and I think that's
what the movies exploring right
exploring those two sides of all of us
you know that are battling constantly
right there's like a side that doesn't
want to be seen and there's a side that
wants to be seen there's a sign that
wants peace and harmony and there's a
side that wants chaos and madness right
and and I think that's really what the
movie deals with on a grand level and
which direction do you decide to take to
take yourself you know and you know I
think in all of us
we try to be good but sometimes we're
fighting or any clinicians to be rageful
and angry and all these things I don't
think there's a person among us who's
not suffering from from that that that
part of ourselves right that's what
being human being is and I think here
you're seeing it explored over the
course of a two-hour movie in a way that
I think is pretty pretty effective you
could even take and this is off going
off on a tangent a little bit but Andy
Kaufman who had that same thing and when
he needed to be larger than life he
could be but then he could be ladka you
know that's right and that was a good
example of somebody who almost seemed
mad like when he decided to be the other
Andy Kaufman the one that was like angry
and it was off in that exact thing right
somebody gentle matched but against
anger right it's like the aggressive
Andy Kaufman that would fight the
wrestler and getting punched by David
you know like the David Letterman Show
all those things it that's a complete
opposite spectrum of his personality but
when he was in that personality was in
it so deeply that he seemed almost mad
right and insane and so yeah I think
it's a good analogy as well since you
had very few meetings with Joaquin
Phoenix correct before shooting
principal photography
how are you building trust with an actor
that's a really good question I think
you build it as you make the movie
honestly I think it's it's you're not
necessarily you know there's a certain
level of trust perhaps
based on your previous work and either
they like the work and they not you know
and not frankly I don't even know I
don't know what Joaquin had seen of mine
outside of what he'd probably seen of
todd's he certainly trusted Todd by
proxy maybe the things that Todd had
done successfully certainly over the
last five films that I've done with him
perhaps that gave Gabe walking in the
trust but I think it's no different than
Todd gaining trust with Joaquin I think
it happens every day
in small ways right and I think you're
just constantly looking to each other
and and and and he's looking for signs
and I'm looking for signs of trust and
we're just trying to find and build that
trust over time and you know that's
every movie and every everybody and
that's sometimes the hardest part is
when you have an actor that comes in for
just a day or two and they've obviously
have a lot of experience and quite you
know good at what they do and in all
those situations or an actor that's just
there for one day you're trying to find
a place to build trust it's one of the
fun things about working on movies is
everything is kind of in hyperspeed you
know you work in an office perhaps you
get to know an office worker over the
course of six months a year and in many
many years but even in an office
situation day one for that person
they're all looking for sign and so yeah
I've worked in some offices that's just
like they said this is part of human
nature right we're just like and I've
always found like that that part of
filmmaking to be a subset that's very
interesting to me is the fact that you
take these disparate people you put them
together they all have special skills
they come together on a project that the
stakes are quite high sometimes they're
made for hundreds of millions of dollars
and and you all have to come together
and work together quite quickly like you
don't have months to get to know each
other you know you often have just days
to get in a situation in which everyone
kind of knows their role the boundaries
who's in charge it's it's a very
eternally find it fascinating just the
way movies work as a as a piece of art
and as a piece of Commerce and and I'm
always interested in that and so you
learned some of those things but I think
for Joaquin
you know it's also he you know he
started watching some stuff played back
on on the monitor and he could watch
some stuff on dailies and I think in
watching that I think he started to
understand what the movie was beyond his
work because you know as an actor he's
doing his thing but he also has to trust
that the editing is gonna work and the
cinematography is gonna work and and
everybody is coming together to like he
might think he's doing this amazing
thing but all that matters is also are
we capturing it you know and if he did
it and we didn't quite capture it well
then nuts then we're not in sync so I
think it's like it's an important you
know aspect of a filmmaking is that
trust thing and I think sometimes you
don't get it and this I think one of the
things I remember texting Todd very
early on I mean I want to say it was
like day three and it was just like a
text of saying oh man I think that our
first three days are going really well
and it wasn't even a kiss I've email I
know Todd for the ages and we were far
from ever kissing each other up but I
was actually genuinely saying how
impressed I was how how well he works
with actors because I've obviously I've
also done it myself in that he's able to
gain trust very quickly and make them
feel like he they're in a really safe
place and that there's a really good
give and take and I just remember
thinking oh this is the movie is working
well so far earlier than I thought
because a lot of movies takes weeks
simply because I could see how much
Joaquin already trusted Todd and I
thought that was that was a good sign
for sure yeah what's the most emotion
you felt filming Joaquin's performance
that's a really good question I mean I
felt that so many different times I felt
it
[Music]
I think we need performs at the comedy
club is a pretty powerful one just
watching him be so exposed on stage sort
of failing and but just carrying on and
just they've something in his eyes and
that scene that has always gets me the
scene when he like is trying to get the
papers from the clerk Brian Tyree Henry
and and that little 101 scene with the
that sort of in between the clerk's the
great that's in front of separating them
this this is just I love that
performance of that scene I find it to
be mesmerizing I'm always sort of
leaning forward when I watch that scene
with him I mean there's probably many
many I'm just trying to think of the
ones that popped in my head at first I
[Music]
think that's seen on the bus
certainly shooting that scene on the bus
we shot that scene it was day two or day
three maybe okay two actually so it was
the second day of our shooting was that
scene on the bus with the with the kid
and the little boy and the like just
seen shooting his side of the action
right it's all cut up obviously like a
scene now but just shooting him perform
that scene that early in the shoot I
went oh my god this guy is something
else this guy is the best I've ever seen
and what he's doing already with this
performance and what he's doing to
create Arthur Fleck as a human being
who's suffering you know I thought it
was beautiful because in that one scene
he's doing everything right he's he
starts having just had gotten beaten up
by a bunch of kids in an alley so he's
coming into the scene still living in
that space looking out the window and
then he's not trying to connect and do
his thing which he's sort of conditioned
to do as a human being but also who he
really is which is to try to make some
little boy smile and then he sort of
reprimanded for it and then goes into
this coughing is this laughing fit which
I think
always embarrasses him because it's on
something he can't control and then has
to hand out this card that describes it
so in that one scene it kind of like
shows all the facets of him as a human
being and I've always found that seem to
be really really powerful and also to
the scene in the bathroom where he
confronts his yes yeah yeah yeah
yeah where he's really truly you know
just reaching in it's like he's just
trying to find a connection you know and
just trying to sort of find that part of
him that's missing you know whether it's
his father or just another person to
help you know be there with him so he's
not so lonely in this world you know and
the scenes with his mother when they
would watch the game show or the talk
shows yeah that's a lovely scene in the
beginning yeah or even when he's washing
her hair it's like it's lovely it's like
this is at least two people have each
other in the world and I think that's
what makes the revelation of her and
what she did to him as a youngster and
you know and and allowing his abuse and
some of those things what makes it
obviously so powerful when it's revealed
sure will you ever laugh or cry while
you're filming no for sure I definitely
laughed
I mean I've laughed out loud obviously
Todd and I've made a bunch of movies in
which not many times but I've certainly
like laughed enough that it's like
gotten on the soundtrack and oh my god
you know we obviously can't affect this
the take but but I've cried in certainly
operating the camera and watching a
scene before for sure for sure I've done
that in movies that I've done I've been
a part of yeah yeah sometimes you just
incredibly moved when you're watching
something happen for real sometimes you
could separate yourself and go into sort
of work mode in which you're you're
thinking about the next shot and Nick
you're not as present as you'd like to
be but when you are watching somebody
work in a really high level and they
really are just performing it you know
in that way it drags you right back into
the present in the bed
way possible and you're compelled to
just have nothing else in your head
except to watch that person perform and
then it can become amazingly powerful
and even if like I'm not sure I I cried
and I certainly laughed watching Joaquin
because there was a lot of physical
humor in the movie that some some of its
not in the movie still but just the way
that he could do you know whatever it
was doing like you know falling down or
just his physicality and you know the
scene when he gets fired and so it was a
little bit of a longer scene than is in
the final cut of the movie and when we
shot that scene there was like there
were sections of that that I just was I
was heartbroken by because he really
wanted that job yeah you recognized that
losing that job was really just it was
very powerful to him and and I remember
when we shot that scene feeling really
moved for sure yeah I think that one was
one of maybe three were yeah I
definitely the tissue out yeah he's
definitely you know again he's a human
being in spite of all that who he
becomes and this sort of like villain
that the Joker is supposed to be at you
know at his heart he still just a man
you